Stefan how um what are your thoughts
about the uh the art in the room behind
you
there uh me it's
special it's kind
of a reminder of how special the uh the
journey has been it's hard to really
like you know reflect or
like uh watch the highlights and all
that just because it's you know we're
still in it and still trying
to chase
more stay competitive you know continue
to evolve as as people and as as
basketball players but every once in a
while you do need a reminder of how
special um and legendary
like you know us three have have have
been you know these 12 years all the
teammates that we've played with over
the course of the the journey jne
and honestly kind of let you smile a
little bit to you know look ahead at the
challenge that's in front of us to you
know
maintain that winning kind of
expectation so it's all all of it is is
really really dope I know you said it's
cool but Steph said it's special to be
able to look at something like that is
do you have any type of feelings like
that about it is it special is it a
reflecting moment yeah
no it's definitely
special it's very rare in pro sports
that you uh get to be teammates with
guys for over a decade and we've done
some pretty historic things together not
satisfied but when you're going to look
uh when you hopefully when our careers
are done you look back
on what we're able to do you can say
it's uh one of the better trios to play
in the NBA so just to be even in that
conversation with some of the greatest
ever play is uh incredibly cool and I'm
a big basketball historian and you know
to look at us three and think that we've
U won
championships you know in the same um
realm as guys like male bird and Parish
or manu Tim and Tony uh hopefully Steph
Kay and Dre will uh leave a legacy like
they did I've got Clay's thoughts what
are your thoughts about seeing that the
specialness of this day and the fact
that you guys have been in a trio for
the last over the last decade oh man
it's it's an incredible incredible
um feeling blessing to play with two
guys like that uh for 12
years the success we've had is great
um the Downs we've had is great you know
they bring us closer and we stick
together through
those um The Journey has been
incredible very thankful to our
Organization for making this happen I
think you know most people get their
flowers when they
die like in our case it wouldn't be
dying but you get your flowers after
you're done you know and for uh for the
organization
to um honor us and and and make it a
point like we didn't have to have a game
today you know just to make it a point
to get it done very appreciative uh you
know it's a great great night great
moment um um but a lot more work to be
done